okay this is one of my favorite exchange
sacrifices because I don't get it
and the computer doesn't get it and then
the guys exchange up resigns so okay
this is I'm sure one of Gary's favorite
games cuz Faraj she robbed from 94
Horgan and who is the only player with
the black pieces not too loose Turkish
Marvin Horgan 94 you it's all about the
Benjamins that's right okay although
Joel told me that he put the Do Not
Disturb sign on his hotel room and kept
getting taken off and wake up was gone
people not kind of door all day so it
wasn't it wasn't me I wasn't there they
probably Gary right okay now as most of
you know Shroff has an excellent record
against gaspar of he didn't want to
blemish it by ever winning okay that's
not not a good record okay and somehow
they transpose to this fashion akov
somehow okay so this is positions
occurred many many many many times
fact Spencer had it last week right yeah
okay and again many many times is this
the main line now still yeah nineteen
years later who would have thunk it
still the main lot she forced him down
the move
okay so c3 c3 still has more games than
it but c4 sketching up okay now as iris
will tell you since we looked at similar
positions today like that's good for
white see that night they're beautiful
you know it's not beautiful is that
night there okay so that night's good
now we got to fix the other night
so c3 the night's going to go to c2 and
go to some somewhere good there's too
many annotations to this game because
probably Kasparov did it I think it's
fantastic actually Bishop d7 92 98
that's modern chess for you remember
when your opponent took your night with
his Bishop although actually was this
night so this Knight wants to go here
and maybe at some point we're going to
sure that night because the night here
doesn't really have any squares
question.what ok night b8 a modern
interpretation by shear of a for
following my rule when their pawns on b5
you play a for incidentally threatening
to win upon takes and he took with the
rook and there's lots of annotations
about not taking with the rook but
putting the knight here to solidify the
center now we see black has an isolated
pawn on a6 and a backward pawn on d6 but
he is the two bishops although I don't
know the ships a little suspicious here
Knight d7
looked to be for solid threatening the
bishop obviously and controlling b6
terrible horrible that's the kind of I
think in one minute
and it usually wins pretty quickly but
in slow chess it never works and there's
lots of notes my favorite note is the
one that says Bishop c6 rook c4 well the
knight c7 chick is annoying I got to
give it to him okay so Knight c5 makes
sense to me rook takes b7 and when this
move was played I think I was watching
the game live or I saw it the next day I
was like huh and when I put on my
computer program Houdini says huh kind
of what was it and for the next few
moves
Houdini just says that black is better
okay although not much better just a
little tiny little better okay there's a
little tiny and move by move White's
position becomes fantastic so this is an
exchange sacrifice which I I barely
understand but the idea is this Knights
here forever
there's no Bishop takes Knight and
conspire is of the opinion that that
Knight is better than any rook also this
weakens the a6 pawn we might take it
later and get a pass B pawn which I
think actually happened um although I'm
not playing that exchange sac and I'm
giving a lecture so that's that so this
is what we call a long-term
exchange sacrifice you're not getting
any pawns you're not getting anything
immediate you're just saying I control
all the white squares I have a white
square bishop this bishop is terrible
this Knight is terrible how do we keep
that night to continue to be terrible
what move could white make so the
Knights terrible forever be for now the
knight can't move anywhere this bishops
not very good and if we can round this
pawn up with our Knights and Bishop and
Queen will have a passed pawn and I
think the most important thing is the
knight on d5 is just there forever
there's never going to be any trade you
know what I'm saying iris you know what
I mean the iris does Iranian Bishop g5
which is typical fashion akov move may
be black I'll play f5 later maybe the
bishop will be good somehow night a3
where's the night going c4 and he does
but I've seen cuddling your knight very
suspicious a5 that's what I would have
played make sense
and he played Bishop to d3 he wants to
keep his pawn on b4
so this Knight has nowhere to go not b5
Knight to c5 don't take the pawn the
night again can go to c5 or take on a5
takes takes and White has a passed pawn
black got rid of his isolated pawn and
activated his rook but that's a poor
Knight and again an exchange sacrifice
sometimes is just saying my minor piece
is better than your ruck and this minor
piece probably wouldn't be here for a 40
moves in a row if that Bishop was there
especially was black playing move like
f5 so it's sort of a defensive sacrifice
he's making sure that black can't do
anything and he's keeping a grip on the
position Queen to b8 the problem is to
suggest a plan for black now Queen B it
makes sense to me because I'm worried
about
one thing I'm worried about this night
on b7 I want to put mine on b7 somewhere
good
like c6 or East six 98 96 96 question
well you agree yeah you agree so Queen
okay so the night's going to go to d8
and get to a normal square h4 cuz
sparrows like well if you put your
pieces over here I'm going to play over
here now me I don't know where's that
Bishop go I would probably go to h6 so I
don't play black in this fashion akov
that right Spencer Bishop h6 Tony who
plays fashion acog Bishop h6 okay and
that's what he did Knight b6 attacking
the rook should black sacrifice the
exchange back well if he does if he does
he had like he has to if he does then
these are the these are why does this
nice pass pawn and black has that pawn
and yeah as you pointed out he can't
really do anything about it
Knight d7 is coming terrible and he just
castles because if he plays 97 Queen a7
now Queen have to mate is annoying and
rook a 1 may be annoying
so after castles black can move his rook
off of f8 castles ripped to d2 that
shear off is tough except when he's
playing Kasparov then he's left off but
when he's not playing me stuff Queen f3
Queen a seven Queens a little suspicious
over there Knight d7 now what do we do
how do we save our rook on f8 if you
move the rook I think 97 check in Queen
f7 is probably good for white that looks
dangerous
but maybe he did move his rook ah look
all these variations No
so rook da well let's see what they are
I didn't put him there somebody did what
happens on rook takes d3 since I don't
know knight c6 Knight f6 9 f8 after
Knight f8 how do you stop Queen g8 maid
yeah I don't know yeah so that's right
so we stopped it g6 man that's a
scary-looking defense there I hate when
that happens
ok so he didn't do that he also gives
Queen a three-night f8 take on d3 Queen
f7 also looking pretty good for white I
don't know about that night on b7
and now the exchange sacrifice makes
sense 20 moves later and the other line
is rook AAA Bishop c4 BAM got in the
rook strap so bishops trap everything's
trapped ok so instead he played in this
position 98 that seems like it avoids
getting mated in the night gets to a
good square cool b5 it's funny now he's
stopping knight c6 he so mean and then
b6 is coming terrible Queen f5 and
taking the bishop is dangerous Queen d7
threatening made everywhere
Queenie sevens May Queen D eights mate I
don't know what you do here he actually
gave a move g6 ok I did see g6
and then black scheme isn't good
terrible terrible what position Queeny
seven queenie 897 queen f8 he's won only
one square at a time I can't do two
squares yeah and I think Queen C it was
much quicker on move 198 then I go to d7
to tease you okay all right so Anna take
he gave that line but I still ignored it
all right so Queen f5 he doesn't wanna
get made it so King he ate setting up
for the next game this ship c4 man eyes
not down the exchange anymore
I hate when that happens and now the
lecture will be on black sacrificing the
exchange except it was an accident
because smog does this move his night
away and when he's like I had a sack
more and play formate and instead of
playing Queen C 4 and then Queen e8
check super-precise he keeps analyzing
Queen C 6 solid alright so instead of
doing that he plays Queen d4 rook a3
with the same Queen takes Knight rook a7
idea Knight e3 threatening Knight f5
check see iris
first there was d5 and others f5 and
somehow she rods exchanged sacrifice not
as good as cos forums they had resigns I
stood all get rook takes b7 I don't get
it
although a I do get it yeah it's funny
he not only killed the the knight on on
b7 t killed his Bishop on h6 - that
Bishop wasn't defending e7 or d8 I hate
when that happens
now the least understandable game is
this one way my color might come in
control F that doesn't work ok this is a
hedgehog where Olaf Anderson sacrifices
exchange for no reason and then he wins
I guess with my lecture ok and he gets
the dark squares ooh okay so this is
Karpov Olaf Anderson if you want to play
off Anderson one minute go on the ICC
and play berta you'll win on time but
your game won't be very good but you
went on time okay so this is like the
movie I made this joke a lot but this
movies getting old what's the movie in
the woods and they have a camera that's
fake with him 10 it's real yeah this
games like The Blair Witch Project
nothing happens nothing happened
something happens it's over okay all
right so nothing ever
happens this game until it happens yeah
this is a hedgehog so nothing's going to
happen
did watches remotes pieces around the
circle
okay so d5 and the hedgehog when
something does happen black plays either
d5 or b5 and then things happen
sometimes sacrificing material okay now
one of the ideas behind the pawn
sacrifice d5 is our Bishop gets to go to
d6 and that's why in hedgehogs today
they're usually playing Bishop c7 a DHS
c7
instead of the ship FA then they're
already on this diagonal and this rook
which you guys are confused as to why
it's here is opened up and since it's an
exchange sacrifice lecture we're ready
to sacrifice the exchange okay this
should be six threatening the pawn on h2
so he plays Knight f1 doesn't want to
lose this pond and then rook takes III
damn and I asked off why did you do that
he says aren't you lecturing on this so
he was any wanted to help me up okay so
this is the longest of the long term
positional exchange sacrifices he's just
like you got your pawn on f3 you
weakened the dark squares around your
king I'm taking that and in fact this
idea of sacking on d5 and attacking h2
and III this is how Kasparov be Karpov
twenty years later
same ideas in the Kings Indian Queen
takes Knight takes X club Knight takes X
clam okay well Queen sakes then it's not
even an exchange sacrifice we could
actually play here and take the rook so
that can't happen that would be bad for
the lecture Knight takes Bishop h2 so
the King is permanently weakened the
dark squares aren't defensible this
Knight can go to g3 the bishop can go to
g3 and more importantly than all of
blacks obvious compensation is the fact
which we saw in the other games the
white rooks just aren't doing it
black is sacrificing a rook for a minor
piece but in effect he's saying my minor
piece is better than your ruck what's
your work doing now if they trade Queens
and White's King gets safe then white
has good winning chances but with the
key Queens on the board and this King
being perpetually open to this bishop on
the diagonal this bishop on the diagonal
this g3 square what a white's works
doing so this is a long-term
compensation 9f one kicking him out he
saves his rook b5 and again you want to
play Knight b6 take the pawn on d5
take away this e4 square gain some space
he's not in a hurry
we were played all fee Anderson and I
have he's not in a hurry in a 1-minute
game he's still not Nuri his moved 12 or
14 you probably won on time not in a
hurry okay now funniest all Fenderson
story I have and I have many nine eleven
one back in the day when I lived in
Europe I was at a tournament in Holland
and he was there I think I don't think
was playing in the press room he was
just in the press room and computers
played on it on the contest's engines
the point on the computer and this was a
long time ago
little Fenderson so I got to play one of
those so he put it in five minutes each
and he's playing it he's displaying the
computer and its roof 12:15 and he's got
like five seconds left so he adds
another five minutes because it's you
know it's on his computer he plays
another 10 moves he's got another five
puts given in there five minutes he kept
giving us off five four minutes if you
never had more time and again was really
boring was like some drunk like this it
was like move around and around around
but I give myself five more minutes he
can't get us off five minutes I was like
an hour to five minutes the game and I
think him in the draw because he went
around in a round so yeah he doesn't
want to play too fast now a lot of
people when they sacrifice material they
have to see the winning knockout blow
punch or they're not going to do it okay
if you sacrifice a piece or a rook I
tend to agree with you but if you're
sacrificing the exchange you know you
got a bishop
your pond has a rock it's not the end of
the world if you go to an ending with
rook versus Bishop then you're probably
going to lose but when there's all these
pieces on the board there's not a big
hurry for black to win more material
there should be 396 as even I said
Knight c4 and again nothing nothing ever
happens I just have dark square control
92 question mark trying to go to B for C
600 here comes Rick h5 doesn't look good
and now move 40 always the losing move
well I think he played the right move is
be the move you played
yeah so 9 G 3 would be a mistake because
Rick that looks terrible for Y who would
play Knight g3 it looks awful yeah this
is looking tough for white like Arbuckle
a knight a terrible sacrificing ya mates
good I guess of Queen takes it's the
same manner we can sack the rough Queen
H to mate yeah that's also good fact
yeah then otherwise Queen g1 and White's
lights still playing
yeah if Queen takes Bishop rook h2 and
Rick h1 and Queen h2 mate
okay so Karpov didn't blonde replay g3
and that Kings look in the little iffy
Queen e8 threatening the e4 pawn rook e1
Bishop to b7 that's my kind of move we
can go to c8 and g4 h3 we can go to a6
now the night comes the g5 and basically
you know this Bishop on the dark squares
is is worth a look look where the white
works are are they active are they
attacking they're defending an e4 pawn
who need who needs rooks
King F 2 the best move I guess and now
he should have played Queenie 7 it says
to get his Queen over to f6 and we're
not done the exchange anymore I were up
two pieces for a rook
so instead he played Bishop d2 which is
also good one his exchange back and
blacks a pawn up and White's King is
ridiculous frankly bishop see that's my
kind of getting the bishop to better
pastures and we're no longer down in
exchange ah rook f1 check those
computers then if King takes bishop here
check wins the Queen and King III looks
a little iffy to me Bishop f5 dubious
Rick f1 winning so he's making Karpov
suffer
it's funny even not down the exchange
White's rook is still not doing very
much
finally a threat
Queen f3 dubious and all fee Anderson
good positional player tactical not so
good
this is what he should have done that's
what he should have done but he played
Queen f3 making him suffer some more and
that's a lot of suffering
and he resigned finally because of king
d - only legal move check check and
check
hurray and that's what we call a
positional exchange sacrifice which took
75 moves to figure out a win but the
point was he had control of the dark
squares the whole game and in the
hedgehog getting your Bishop open on
this diagonal or this diagonal that's
what's material and if we can go back a
little earlier well I mean a lot earlier
let's just leave and come back the other
way the way they're playing the Hedgehog
now in these types of positions is
instead of playing rook e8 and Bishop FA
is well usually this Knight is here but
it took him a few moves to do that is
there playing rook c8 Queen c7 Queen b8
then Bishop here Bishop here
the queen of Bishop are lined up and
then we try to play d5 and that's one of
the problems with white and this kind of
Hedgehog when the bishops fianchettoed
there's a pawn on g3 when the bishop is
here g3 doesn't make any sense
if you don't play g3 you're going to
have to play h3 or lose your aged pawn
and then you're making some weaknesses
at your King there
so if Karpov was a better positional
player then he could have been ok right
now since I'm since I'm dissing Karpov
and he's on the wall and I'm not we're
going to show one of my favorite games
from Karpov and now I'm going to discus
part of brutally here yeah I wish she
was here so I can make fun of him
okay so Kasparov said before this
tournament whoever wins this tournament
is the best tournament player in the
world specifically this tournament when
arias 94 all that all the best players
were there Anand was like the worst like
why was he invited okay and Karpov
crushed everybody
the smacked he got like 10 out of 13 so
he got like two points were thing
tomorrow before the tournament as
problems like this term will decide and
he he forgot he said that now this is
what my favorite Karpov game that has
some tactics in it most of his games are
sort of like he grinds you out
this is against Topalov before top lot
was topple of maybe he wasn't cheating
it I don't know okay no those are just
rumors okay
nobody from Bulgaria would ever cheat at
the top level of course I'm making fun
of what's his name Boris log well even I
was his last name I recently became
friends with French Grandmaster Romy ed
doir on Facebook and the reason was he
said I'm going to a tournament a few
days and I see even off his
pre-registered and he actually got him
unproduced 'red he's been banned from
the tournament even though they can't
really legally banned banned him anyway
he's actually banned in Bulgaria but not
any other country so but yeah I mean
even of I don't want to say anything on
camera he's the biggest cheater ever
ever he's the world champion of cheating
he should be in true romance he's the
world heavyweight champion of cheating
okay that guy okay here's how he's
cheating here's how you know he's
cheating not because his moves are good
not because their computer was not
because he wins that's not why I know
he's cheating when they show him playing
he's like this and then he makes a move
you do that flight chance and don't move
your head down with your eyes see how
good you play just sit like this and see
how well you play right he never he
never looks at other games never loses
it never sits up his Jesus like this
because you know they've got to see
something's got to see what's going on
yeah that's funny watching video of him
playing okay so this is Karpov topalov
and there will be no bono knees today or
20 years ago
yeah yeah that's a boring opening we
know man 20 years ago this was a bad
position to have against Karpov with
black terrible passive and solid that's
not what you wanted against card above
you wanted like unclear complicated
Karpov gets in a time trouble not not
this okay Knight h5 Karpov is like
whatever III and now after takes a takes
this just it just puts a clamp on these
squares open files and this Bishop is
terrible so very instructive I've never
seen this III EF in this variation I
like it and just plays like Karpov
nothing special puts his rooks in the
middle okay he was going to play f5 next
move
so nope h4 h5 softens them up topple off
can't take it anymore b5 you can't take
it it's got to get activity and now with
the H pawns gone this is all softened up
here this pawn can easily get overloaded
now I'm sure all of you were here last
month for my lecture on my game with
Fidel holly's Jimenez right and that
game I took on e6 he played f e6 I play
queen g6 and I mated him there after
Knight c5 BAM so Karpov maneuvering his
Knights to better squares but top block
doesn't handle that he just takes it
takes now there's some slight pressure
here on c6 and this actually had to be
calculated very accurately because white
doesn't want to lose his queen that
would be bad rook c8 and the idea is
while top loves idea if you take the
knight then I could attack the Queen
rook c7 or Rick a7 the Queen moves away
then I take back and black is fine
now when you think a car Bob you think
wild aggressive tactician right indeed
so what a car pop do in this position
hmm
rook takes he six indeed yeah the
problem is black black put always like I
can stand right here likes pieces are
all over there okay not good if all your
pieces are over here then your king is
going to get in trouble and he's going
to sacrifice his rook again if it's not
taken he's got another place to
sacrifice it
so yeah this exchange sacrifice is
working how quiet well we're going to
checkmate our opponent and take all
their pawns
if we don't checkmate them we're still
winning because bikes rooks are terrible
Rick a7 and now what Rick g6 if I
remember correctly that's right I've
been wrong before rug g6 now King h8
Queen h3 is the funniest that's the
funniest and the problem is when you do
take my rook I'm going to win this night
and I'm sort of ahead material King h7d
play King h7 no if King h7 Karpov gives
you the Smackdown check oh actually it
says rook g4 is even better
Rick g4 are you kidding me are you
kidding me and then rook h1 me Oh
a.m. that's a safe King but not too safe
yeah now two pawns too far yeah okay but
okay
I'm guessing that wasn't what Karpov was
planning he was probably thinking
everything wins and you know this this
is more likely what he was thinking you
know that easily winning nothing to
calculate yeah well I would be shocked
if Karpov KXAS queen and play King Jeter
the car would do that not knock on fun
okay so FG six takes an okay a bike is
just crushed this is a great exchange
sack as you're sort of ahead material to
start with and as Yassir would say as he
said so many times before when it's
obviously colored bishops the attack is
even stronger it's hard to defend g6 and
if you know the famous white square
Symphony game between Karpov and
Kasparov Karpov gets his Queen and
Bishop in there with regularity rug d8
and now Karpov starts taking things
greedy damn still taking stuff you're d1
I like like works that good on a1 let's
go to d1 and now after Queen takes a six
you thought I was done you thought this
is the last game in my lecture and I
already showed you the exchange
sacrifice
ah but you only thought I showed you the
exchange sacrifice BAM rook takes d4
Karpov was given two rugs so you could
sacrifice two exchanges yeah now man
it's not easy to defend when all the
guys pieces are all over you there yeah
that bishop on d4 was pretty good not
anymore
so it's funny you sacrifice the exchange
because you're you want to get a good
minor piece then when your opponent gets
the better minor piece you sacrifice it
again just for the other reason like
that bishop was good on d4 get rid of
that all right which way do we take the
answer is it doesn't matter okay he took
with the rook he takes with the pawn
Queen f6 check takes up the rook on d8
with mate I think and terrible okay so
he takes with rook check doesn't matter
what he does and all his pawns are gone
ah
and there's no more pawns and now we
have a bishop and five pawns for a rook
and the only person who would like black
here is Virge am it's funny because it's
true for those of you who don't get that
how many days ago was the tournament on
Saturday Virge shadow rook for Bishop
and four pawns and he won so he's like
yeah I won
Oh No b3 aha that'll show him King G to
that exit King G cheese like I had
enough because the Queen's defending
this and down five pawns well though if
it was Karpov version we've seen a lot
more moves yeah so I like that game
because he said two exchanges anyb
Topalov and he won the term by like a
million points the others beat everybody
that tournament so to me that was his
greatest tournament ever but this
exchange sacrifice of the second one for
different reasons the first exchange
sacrifice actually won material the
second one was the bishop on d4 was
blacks only good piece it was pressuring
f2 it was defending f6 it had to go and
then you know usually five pawns has
become